breaking tonight supporters of
anti-government activities
in cuba are pressuring the biden
administration to take action
they're doing it physically outside the
white house this follows the havana
government's most recent crackdown on
dissent
correspondent david spot reports tonight
on these new protests here in washington
good evening david hi brett today july
26th is the day
the communist regime in cuba celebrates
the 1959 revolution also today as you
mentioned
tens of thousands of cuban americans not
just in washington but around the
country
took to the streets hoping that regime
comes to an end
and soon
[Applause]
once again cuban americans brought their
concerns about the situation
in their home country to lafayette park
across the street from the white house
hoping
to get the attention of the president
himself we spoke to one man
who fled cuba as a little boy
the cuban people need help we need an
intervention
we are here to let him know that we are
fighting for our freedom
cuban americans and supporters alike
marched from the white house on
pennsylvania avenue down to the cuban
embassy
another way to mark this july 26th
[Music]
i call upon the president in this white
house
to support the people of cuba and not
the castro regime
[Applause]
we need a maximum pressure campaign on
the regime the white house is under
pressure from republicans and democrats
to try to restore the internet in cuba
the communist regime there cut off all
internet ties to keep the world
out of the situation there on the ground
we are quite focused uh and interested
in restoring internet access to the
people of cuba
uh and we feel uh if we can get it done
that would be a great step forward
and and beneficial to the people of cuba
house minority leader kevin mccarthy and
other republicans want a meeting with
the president himself
this white house is joining 20 other
nations brett to condemn the regime for
arresting hundreds following protests
last week
but for many cuban americans that is
simply not enough they want more
and they want immediate help brett all
right david we'll follow it thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else